you've obviously had phenomenal success
you're extremely popular but there's
this downside to it every time i i'm
checking out
you know in a 7-11 or something i see
the tabloids i think 80 of the time now
they're they're writing about you isn't
that is that get to be like a pain in
the neck at a certain point or do you
have a sense of humor about it no no
well at first i had no sense of humor
about it nothing was funny at all but
now you have to i mean you have to you
there's no way around it but there's not
one word of it that's ever true
except that one oh no uh
well they follow you to they follow you
on vacation don't you yeah and that's
the worst part especially when you're
you know you're out on vacation and
there was one time we were you know i
was in flip-flops you know rubber
flip-flops and and it started raining
and of course there's
photographers so you're trying to run as
you run from them i was running from
them at that point well no it was
actually running because it started
raining and you understood the whole
thing sure and you know uh
of course you're on ancient marble
and it's flip-flops and it's raining and
i fell right on my ass
and that was fun and that's you know
just think all you think is oh my god
that's just the last thing you need yeah
and then i ran as quickly as i could
took my shoes off and i go into the holy
cathedral and my bare feet and i'm sorry
you hid in a church because paparazzi
can't follow you into a church
yeah they're like vampires
yeah
uh
also they probably when you fall they
get a picture of that and then say
aniston drunk
yeah wasted she's drunk again honor ass
drunk yeah but somehow that didn't end
up anywhere lucky for me oh it will now
was there have you ever seen one where
you thought like well that's just so
that's just funny it's so ridiculous
like you're just like oh that's it makes
you laugh like it's it's humorous to you
well well i think by now i i'm married i
have children and you know i've had the
greek tibetan wedding i mean all these
how do they make up something like that
like you had a greek tibetan like that's
that's not just lying like you secretly
got married they're coming up with
specific weird lines yeah no they're
very detailed there's some little guy or
chick sitting in that room who just has
nothing better to do than
make you know somebody try to try to
find a good story i don't know i i envy
you in a way because i've only had two
tabloid stories written about me and the
whole time i've been on the kourtney
that's three that was the only good one
they link me they link me romantically
to courtney cox i gotta admit i phoned
that one in
she's in love with him who is this conan
uh
that was crazy i'm sure that thrilled
her but anyway oh no it's funny but uh
no the two that i'm talking about like
that was that one was just crazy and
then the two ones the main ones that
have like it's been in the tables and i
clipped them out and i've talked about
this before one was he has high
cholesterol
and they had a picture of me looking
and then the other one was he doesn't
wash his hands after he uses the
bathroom like what was that picture what
did that look like
but i'm like what are you talking about
you know those are pathetic stories i
wish they were chasing me around some
paradise
talk to them will you have them come up
with something better
you um
i'm i was surprised to find something
out which today uh the producer who was
talking to you said that you told him
that
you went to the doctor
and he you went to the eye doctor oh
what you don't want to talk about this
no it's just silly well oh that's why we
don't
know
you're on this show
the doctor told you you're cross-eyed
well in a subtle yes and basically you
know you you go i'd always gotten my
glasses done you know lens crafter and
you go in the back and they go
there's your prescription you know they
go like that to you
that is not a that is not a doctor he's
tricking you well now i know that right
no so i went to a real eye doctor and
got the full checkup and you know you
fill out this form basically asking you
all of these questions that you start to
go huh so my childhood was tortured
because of something other than that i
was just an inadequate kid like you know
can you throw a ball do you have trouble
catching a ball can you read you do you
switch words and i'm thinking yes these
are all the things that you know i'd
nobody picked me on their teams because
i was just a crappy athlete right right
and it was all because she said well you
have conjunctive access or something and
i said what does that mean she said well
it means your cross side
but i'm looking at you you're not
cross-eyed i always think cross-eyed's
like i love you please
it's a little muscle thing
i mean you don't look anything like this
at all
no it's when i do that that actually
yeah that was evil and cross-eyed but
you just did yeah my mother used to
always say to me when i was a kid you
keep doing that it'll stay that way and
sure enough your faith my mom would tell
me that i was always making faces as a
kid like i don't now but she would say
it's going to freeze and you'll be
trapped that way and i i thought cool
that would be cool yeah i wish i had a
cool looking face like that uh
we we um
you know you're now
there's so many young people now that
probably have posters of you and
whatever you know i mean just cause
you're a big star now there's so many
kids that would think of you as you know
whatever their idol or something who
when you were a kid when you were young
who was your who'd you have a crush on
who was your idol
on tv
i
i loved sean cassidy i loved um uh scott
baio
scott baio
how into scott baio were you oh i was
very i was gonna marry scott bale
my father whipped around in the car one
day you are not going to marry scott
baio stop that
my father said the same thing to me did
he really
yeah
it was an odd kid yeah but you had the
posters and posters i listen joni loves
chachi you know i didn't have we would
record i didn't have a vcr so i'd take
our tape recorder and put it next to the
tv and
record the shows and then i'd play them
at night you just listened to me she
would listen to the audio of joni loves
chachi
wow
i feel so bad yeah
i've gotten over it did you uh does he
know this if you ever you mean you're
jennifer anson now you could you could
meet him were you any interested in that
at all in meeting him
he's not backstage or anything don't
worry
everyone here is like they're gonna
bring him out
here he is no we're not no no i mean
i've i've actually met i met him once
i was over the crush though so you know
what i was gonna say you're like oh
um
what um what's your uh what is it you
watch on tv now like what's the show
that you just it's like your guilty
pleasure
oh my guilty i have
late night those late night things you
know like
well the real world
when you said late night i got all
excited for a second but then
no i was just thinking because last
night i was watching this forget it this
interview's over
you so stuck on me in here like those
late night things uh you know uh the
real world
what's that oh that's your little i see
what's that that's what tells me where
you're going what to talk to me about
okay
what did you think this was
information about me
i get depressed oh i'm an aries i'm
curious
i'm 6'4
i like volleyball and that gives me a
few notes
segways go i'm sorry oh no you just
exposed the sham that these talk shows
really are
no real world come on real world tell me
was the real world one of the shows that
you enjoyed as a child
yeah you watched that show i would no
because last night i was watching this
thing on poker
you know professional poker players
right
if anybody saw that
anyone
but it was fascinating it was actually
fascinating you got your finger on the
pulse of america really didn't you all
see that in a crowd no
i've never heard a whole crowd going
yeah i love poker
i love to play poker
more than anything one of you know and
and it was just to see these guys these
are professional poker players and their
dream is to be in the olympic poker
championships and it's just a whole
nother world that i you know didn't it's
in the olympics that's what this guy was
saying i want to be in the olympic poker
championship but i think that guy you're
a little delusional i don't know if that
dick actually exists right they have to
combine it with some kind of athletic
thing like run 30 yards with a baton
stop play some poker fire a rifle uh
uh
no you're a fan of the real world
someone was saying
we gotta go uh
no i was i real world san francisco and
she lost her all of it and she got
kicked out let's talk about this later
on our on our pink princess phones
[Laughter]
we'll see that i have my wide now see i
have a scott bale picture behind me
uh or is it bio uh well friends like i
have to mention this i always feel some
friends by the way it's thursday's at
eight on nbc if you want to know where
that is and uh this is exciting hosting
ceremony live this weekend is this your
first time yeah oh this'll be cool uh
and musical guests stink that's a great
show hey thanks for making time for us i
know you're busy before that's fine
jennifer thank you very much jennifer
aniston everybody
tim burton is coming up we'll take a
break we'll be right back
you